la chasse aux faux seins faux avec vos
anthony st léger bonjour bonjour vous
emmener d'abord donc sur les terrains de
la can oui les pelouses des stades dont
l'état est critiquée depuis que la
compétition commence et même avant
d'ailleurs car jugée impraticable et que
ce soit sur facebook ou twitter et bien
on peut trouver ce genre de commentaire
regardez ici cette page facebook publie
cette photo où on y voit des personnes
aspergeant l'herbe jaunie de peinture
verte avec cette légende l'une l'un des
stades du cameroun qui accueillait qui
accueille l'as cannes plusieurs
publications qui par exemple
et affirmait aussi que c'était des
photos qui avait fuité avant
l'organisation alors le cameroun
était-il pas assez mûrs trop vert pour
organiser cette can en tout cas ce n'est
pas cette photo qui permet de l'affirmer
parce que cette photo est bien elle n'a
absolument rien à voir avec la can c'est
ce que nous apprend une recherche
d'image inversée elle est d'ailleurs
régulièrement utilisés pour faire de
l'un des informations liées à la can
c'était le cas par exemple en 2017 vous
voyez ici ce site et qui j'y tiens
pardon à qui monterait à tort cette
image pour une can au gabon en 2010 est
donc qui évoquait le stade de port
gentil ça n'avait rien à voir et puis
c'était le cas aussi de ce site marocain
cette fois on est en 2014 qui assurait
que la photo provenait d'un stade de
guinée équatoriale quelques mois avant
donc l'organisation en 2015 à 2 cette
femme scan alors d'où vient cette photo
eh bien rien à voir avec la can je vous
le disais on n'est même pas en afrique
on est en asie cette image on la
retrouve ses selles tout simplement du
stade ii ou naouna tec 10 est à
naypyidaw la capitale de birmanie et en
étant en 2013 on la retrouve par exemple
dans un reportage sur ces 27e jeux
sportifs d'asie du sud est donc rien à
voir avec la can et ce site
d'information thaïlandais par exemple
critique est d'ailleurs à l'époque que
les employés et du peintre justement la
pelouse de ce stade pour cacher sous le
tapis les défauts des pelouses des
stades à on passe au cours de tennis
l'open d'australie qui a débuté il y a
maintenant quelques jours et qui va
continuer à se dérouler tout au long de
la semaine prochaine effectivement avec
enserre novak djokovic qui a défrayé la
chronique ce numéro un mondial non
vaccinés qui a finalement fini par être
expulsé par les autorités australiennes
et c'est justement dans ce contexte que
des internautes saisissent la balle au
bond pour affirmer que plusieurs joueurs
ont dû abandonner la compétition du fait
de problèmes respiratoires liés au
vaccin contre le coc vide exemple dans
ce tweet par exemple qui affirme donc
seul djokovic était le joueur en bonne
santé parce que non vaccinés qui publie
regardez cette vidéo où on voit cette
joueuse en l'occurrence la slovène d'al
hilal jakupovic à bout de souffle qui
finit à genoux sur le coup alors une
scène qui peut être vous rappelle
quelque chose et pour cause parce que si
vous cherchez dans un moteur de
recherche d'al hilal jakupovic avant
dont vous retombez sur des articles de
janvier 2020 notamment celui ci on est
en open d'australie c'est vrai mais la
raison ce manque de respiration ça n'a
rien à voir avec le co vide on est en
australie et l'australie connaît à
l'époque d'importants feux de forêts qui
rendent l'air totalement irrespirable à
l'époque un ramasseur de balle avait
d'ailleurs fait un malaise donc rien à
voir avec le coc u19 nil vaccin qui
n'existaient pas les deux d'ailleurs et
la slovène ne fait d'ailleurs pas partie
des joueuses sélectionnées est cette
année et puis il y à d'autres exemples
effectivement dans qui sont du même
acabit par exemple l'australien nick
argos qui se tient levante qui fait une
grimace que l'on voit ici à droite cette
photo est aussi utilisé bien quand vous
menez une recherche semblables on trompe
très vite sur un article d'eurosport on
est en juillet dernier à wimbledon et
l'australien est tout simplement blessé
aux abdominaux contraint d'abandonner
avant les huitièmes et nikkei aux qui
cette année à participer à l'open et qui
a été éliminé aujourd'hui par danila
medvedev et il ya un autre exemple
beaucoup plus récent celui de nico l'os
basile et willy que l'on voit ici une
photo qui le monde se tenant le thorax
il ya aussi des vidéo qui le montre en
présence de son staff médical et qui
semble effectivement avoir des
difficultés pour respirer et bien non il
n'a pas abandonné l'open en raison du
coc vide là encore c'est une recherche
tout simplement sur un moteur de
recherche avec trois mots son prénom son
nom
le mot abandon il y en a on apprend et
bien que sonné pas à l'open d'australie
mais à la coupe atp donc avant l' open
et l'open il en a été éliminé le 18
janvier dernier face à andy murray est
la mère de ce joueur a d'ailleurs
affirmé que son fils avait eu coville et
que c'est certainement les restes de ce
qu vide qui explique ses difficultés
respiratoires merci anthony info ou
intox été remis